mes chers amis que de chemin parcouru en
un an
je me souviens mon cher marc philippon
cher gérald mon cher bernard mon cher
daniel est revenue ici devant vous il ya
tout juste un an j'étais à l'époque le
secrétaire général de notre mouvement
qui traversait des moments difficiles
souvenez vous ces moments terribles où
notre mouvement a été ballottée près par
les divisions internes où il a eu la
faille ne pas survivre mais vous vous
êtes mobilisés
vous nous avez dit de nous rassembler
vous avez été exigeants vis-à-vis de vos
dirigeants
nous avons organisé une élection
incontestable vous avez choisi votre
président vous avez choisi nicolas
sarkozy
et je veux lui rendre hommage pour le
travail accompli depuis un an
que de chemin parcouru il a su apaiser
les tensions il a su rassembler la
famille il a su composer une équipe de
sensibilité différente oui nous sommes
nombreux mais nous sommes différents et
ce qui fait notre force chez les
républicains
c'est que justement nous venons
d'horizons différents et bien il a su en
un an composer un bureau politique de
personnalité forte capable de se
rassembler autour d'un même projet et
bien c'est aujourd'hui les jeunes vous
qui montre l exemple sur marvin cher
geoffrey je vais vous en remercier vous
montrer le chemin du rassemblement
rien ne devra pouvoir nous diviser alors
jamais sans doute depuis très longtemps
jamais peut-être depuis 1958
notre responsabilité à nous la droite et
le centre à nous les républicains n'aura
été aussi grande
entrent à l'instant gerald de l'évoquer
entre un front national dont chacune des
propositions conduirait à ruiner notre
pays est un parti socialiste qui a
commencé à le faire
y at il véritablement une alternative
crédible
y at il un espoir pour les français
pouvons-nous encore incarner un espoir
d'avenir pour les français l'enjeu est
là la démagogie c'est facile
souvenez-vous de peggy morts au champ
d'honneur
il ya cent ans qui disait le triomphe de
la démagogie est passager les ruines
sont éternelles
nous avons à construire nous avons à
construire je me tourne vers vous les
jeunes républicains la france du xxième
siècle
la france n'est pas aujourd'hui entrer
dans le 21e siècle
c'est donc un défi considérable jamais
les socialistes n'ont été aussi
éloignées des préoccupations des
français sont jezzy à la rochelle un
atelier s'intituler travailler moins
travailler tous il évoqué je le cite la
sixième semaine de congés payés la
retraite à 60 ans et même une année
sabbatique pendant que les socialistes
dit certes dû travailler moins
travailler mieux les salariés du groupe
industriel smart dans l'automobile vote
l'allongement de la durée du travail
c'est ça la division entre les
socialistes et les français quels
fracture qu'elle fracture au sein même
de ce gouvernement
l'année dernière la rentrée du président
de la république a été gâchée parce
qu'il y avait un mini ce qui était trop
à gauche
cette année pas de chance elle est
gâchée parce qu'un ministre qui est trop
à droite
mais où va-t-on dans ce gouvernement où
va-t-on entre la bonne conscience de
monsieur valls
monsieur macron qui a besoin de 49,3
pour ouvrir des nouvelles lignes
d'autocars et la mauvaise conscience de
monsieur hollande
monsieur montebourg oui la mauvaise
conscience
celui qui lui rappellent en permanence
son discours du budget du bourget savez
la taxe à 75% le l'ennemi c'est la
finance cette mauvaise conscience qui
revient régulièrement et bien entre le
fantôme du bourget et le farfadet du
social libéralisme il va bien falloir
que monsieur hollande choisissent
ce serait risible si la situation
économique n'était pas celle que l'on
connaît alors heureusement la reprise
est là 14 juillet 2013
la reprise est là 14 juillet 2014
la reprise est là 14 juillet 2015
la reprise est là oui monsieur le
président la reprise est là
la reprise est là aux états unis qui
vont faire 3 7% de croissance cette
année
la reprise est là en grande bretagne qui
a créé 2 6 millions d'emplois en quatre
ans
la reprise est là en allemagne qui a
créé 1,6 million d'emplois en quatre ans
mais la reprise n'est pas là en france
elle n'est pas là parce que françois
hollande
ces gouvernements ont asphyxié
l'économie par une taxation excessive
sur les ménages par une énormité une
absurdité taxer le capital au niveau du
travail
jamais aucun autre pays n'avait osé
c'est stupide pourquoi c'est stupide bas
parce que le capital en général il vient
du travail parce qu'ensuite le capital
il est mobile aujourd'hui
donc si vous taxer le capital qu'est ce
qu'il fait il s'en va + 40 %
d'augmentation des départs en 2013
aujourd'hui il y à une fuite des talents
dans notre pays il ya une fuite des
cerveaux
il y à une fuite des forces vives j'ai
présidé à l'assemblée nationale une
commission d' enquête sur l'exil de ses
forces vives et bien les socialistes ne
veulent pas regarder cette réalité en
face
oui la situation économique est
difficile et la politique de lutte
contre le chômage de monsieur hollande
un véritable fiasco
même le ministre du travail a réussi à
pau mais son boulot c'est vous dire
marquer il devait pas travailler plus de
35 heures 1
et même ils seraient passés aux 32 qu'on
aurait même rien vu non mais rebsamen
vous avez vu le toupet monsieur rebsamen
quitte après deux mois de
démissionnaires le sujet du chômage est
le dossier numéro 1 de gouvernement et
pendant deux mois le ministre est
démissionnaire et il nous dit je cite
ouvrez les guillemets j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir bien fait mon travail
quelle indécence
quelle indécence ce n'est pareil ça même
qu'un démissionner c'est le gouvernement
face au chômage
alors mes chers amis nous aurons
beaucoup de travail je sais j'entends
monter le mais on a tout essayé contre
le chômage
mes chers amis on a peut-être tout
essayé sauf ceux qui marchent
regardez la grande bretagne regardez
l'allemagne
regardez la façon dont ils sont arrivés
au plein emploi en libérant le marché du
travail en mettant en place de nouveaux
contrats de travail en flexibilise ans
le temps de travail
le premier ministre veut réformer le
code du travail
il ne veut toucher ni aux contrats
travail n'est autant de travail ni à la
rémunération mais là on touche à quoi
qu'est ce qui reste
nous aurons donc une mission
considérable dans ce nouveau monde
ce nouveau monde qui nous attend c'est
un monde que vous allez appréhendez vous
les jeunes républicains et je vous
demande de nous aider à répondre à ces
défis du 21e siècle
nous vivons aujourd'hui dans un monde
mondialisé et un monde de l'économie de
la connaissance
parfois même dans nos rangs j'entends
certains douter
critiquer la mondialisation mais mes
chers amis la mondialisation c'est pas
une option c'est pas un choix politique
c'est un fait
elle s'impose à nos la mondialisation
c'est la contraction du temps et de
l'espace
il nous faut donc l'accompagner ce monde
de la connaissance de l'économie de la
connaissance qui est celui de tous les
possibles
songez que nous avons depuis l'an 2000
effectué plus de découvertes que dans
les sept mille premières années de
l'espèce humaine
ce monde qui s'accélère celui de la
connaissance
eh bien il nous tend les bras nous avons
à y répondre et nous ne répondrai pas
par des recettes d'hier par des recettes
du passé nous avons besoin d'être plus
agile que les autres nous avons besoin
d'être plus réactif que les autres
nous avons besoin d'être plus déterminés
que les autres c'est cela qui nous
faudra préparer à travers le projet des
républicains alors mes chers amis jeunes
républicains je vous le demande
aidez-nous
nous les républicains à incarner cette
france du 21ème siècle a passé ce cap du
siècle du 21e siècle c'est ça notre défi
c'est comme ça que nous retrouverons la
confiance des français
merci